ooh lol it's like a cyclist t he keeping
me down down down down hey hey what's
going on YouTube how was your week how
are you doing how do you feel you look
[ __ ] good you get robbed somebody
touch you where am i or am I going with
this family can we talk about this for a
second I gotta say one of my favorite
things in this world has to be the
youtube comment section we're not just
YouTube in general own Instagram or any
type of social media that allows you to
just write your [ __ ] thoughts
anywhere now because I've been away from
YouTube for a while now I gotta say I
kind of forgot what that [ __ ] was like
my god boys I don't know straight boys
at me if you wanted to find a place to
find somebody to fall ass-first into a
dick shape corkscrew the youtube comment
section would be a good place to start
now don't get me wrong the youtube
comment section can be great because
it's a place where we get to interact
and honestly YouTube was built upon this
foundation but out of the good 90% of
you [ __ ] out there there's that
good [ __ ] 10% of Dookie flakes to
everywhere and that's 10% of these
[ __ ] that do exist do you realize
that they all share very similar traits
so you know I gotta go in on this and
it's been a minute but you already know
what it is
LGI penny let's get it let's go why is
it that every dumb [ __ ] that has
something stupid or moronic to say never
has a profile picture to go along with
their stupid [ __ ] comments you are
the faceless [ __ ]
[Music]
you pump big chicken dick licking and
growth Wow if you got balls enough to
talk [ __ ] about somebody online you
should at least put a [ __ ] picture to
your [ __ ] name [ __ ] Lasky [ __ ] I
want to see the face I want to spit on
but you don't have a picture because in
case you write something that obviously
people won't like you could just crawl
back the [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] you came
from but if one person likes your
comment you get a thumbs up all I bet
your little dick gets hype oh please
somebody like my comment and validate my
existence why you got a picture huh you
got a scrotum for a face which ass
lookin like The Hunchback from 300h I
bet you so ugly you look like how your
daddy dick smells walking around with
your coochie lookin like corned beef and
span it's weird because people are
telling me like David you should feel
bad for this person because most likely
they're behind their sticky [ __ ] stain
keyboard waiting for somebody to like
them but no I don't want to be the
bigger person I hope it elephant lands
on your [ __ ] face why is it that
every time you say something so [ __ ]
stupid
and you get called out for it suddenly
you become an expert on the subject ah
the YouTube [ __ ] /
[Music]
how many times have we seen on a comet
where you write something so [ __ ]
dumb the whole community [ __ ]
destroys you then I don't know where
you'll become an expert on the subject
on something you knew nothing about
three seconds ago Michael Jordan is such
a overrated basketball player what the
[ __ ] are you talking about don't you
think there's a reason why everybody
till this day compares their skill set
to what Michael Jordan has done for
Olympic basketball player I think I know
what I'm talking about when it comes to
be a ball I will stab you in the [ __ ]
throat
by chance my god but it's not just for
Sports is for anyone or anything that
this person doesn't have a valid
argument for actually I'm comparing pick
and Ionis man listen here just to put a
straight in case you didn't know
nobody [ __ ] believes you you deranged
[ __ ] just think about it for a second
how the [ __ ] can we believe you do you
really think that if somebody was high
into like as you state that you are
carrying [ __ ] AIDS you wouldn't be on
YouTube come to get right back to
[ __ ] thirteen-year-old spike there's
a surgeon out there conducting
open-heart surgery scalpel I think she's
going to make it hold on a second
Santa's not real [ __ ] [ __ ] that in
and of itself already disproves your
self-proclaimed sense of higher
intelligence you not [ __ ] idiot
like I can't you know I read a common
once that was so [ __ ] stupid and
nearly it's uploaded by keyboard
somebody basically wrote this stupid
[ __ ] comment about the topic of
sexual assault and rape that the person
who gets raped it's basically the
victims fault something stupid along
those lines so somebody wrote back hey
listen if you have somebody in your
family that experienced this type of
situation maybe you would empathize more
so then this other person writes back I
[ __ ] you not well actually you be glad
to hear my mom actually was raped what
the you'll be glad to hear my mom was
actually raped dude you just don't want
to lose do you actually you'd be glad to
know if my kidneys exploded yesterday
don't you just love it when you break
somebody down with kindness and logic
and the only thing they could respond
back to is her why the hell is it that
every time somebody writes me crazy
prejudice or racist [ __ ] at the end of
the comment they always write by the way
I could say this because I'm black
you're what we call the bitch-ass racist
[Music]
what okay for everybody who writes that
let's just say that's true and that's
your defense or argument that is ten
times worse you're [ __ ] self-hating
[ __ ] and by the way you ain't fooling
nobody black or Asian or Mexican it's
like all yeah [ __ ] because you
wrote you're Asian or black you fooled
us now and by the way ethnic mystery men
because you are the proposed ethnicity
that you say you are what the [ __ ] is
your profile picture oh it's always on
some tip like first of all Asian people
are inferior to white people and I must
say that they need to leave this [ __ ]
country and by the way oh you should
have told me in the foot plane like I'm
trying to figure out the logic behind
this thing because even if you are that
ethnicity or race how does that make it
okay once again it just makes you a
self-hating son-of-a-bitch and by the
way you're also the worst type of races
because not only are you ignorant as
[ __ ] you're also a punk-ass [ __ ]
because you can't even own up to your
hate you're seriously trying to lie to
get people of a certain ethnicity to
hate their own ethnic background is the
saddest [ __ ] thing I've ever seen in
my life it's so obvious and transparent
is the equivalent of doing this now if
you're asking me the only way for us to
combat these [ __ ] idiots is for us
smart people to come together and crush
them like little tiny [ __ ] ball sacks
you guys do a great job of shutting
people down and I gotta say makes me
want to cry
what I'm saying is everybody let the
smart people rise to the top and crush
the dumb [ __ ] all the way down if I
ever see you hand jobs on me no lotion
all hands chalk LeBron James down oh
I've been known of these in a while my
[ __ ] throat
why hello everybody I hope you guys
enjoyed that video and yes remember if
you have any any topics you want me to
talk about give you life advice news
articles reactions whatever I'm here for
you let's interact let's make this
happen because guess what next year
starting up I'm gonna be auditioning
like a [ __ ] so I need y'all to
help me out on this because I could talk
for days about [ __ ] but why don't
you
- involved it's weird looking at my face
in this camera you like that
you're we call the bitch-ass rapist oops
not rapist racist